time for this week's pet project and Amy
Lee joins us from the NSP CA and she
brought along some furry friends that
need good homes I did and on - I have
Pippa here who is a beautiful little
baby girl and you've got I have Patrick
they are siblings on the same litter but
they are so sweet and we are so excited
to find loving homes for these guys
we've got a lot of cats it's obviously
kitten season so with that we've just
got a lot of kittens
yeah so they all need great holiday need
homes and a lot of people are at home
right now working from home so this is a
perfect up it really really is - yes
they're really we've got a great adult
cats looking for homes as well but these
little guys are looking for homes we're
gonna actually be at Petsmart this week
so Friday and Saturday will be there
from 10:00 to 2:00 at the look the 70/50
a royal crossing Parkway location so
tell me a little bit about and Patrick
they are so sweet how old are they 16
weeks old and they've actually been with
their foster mom who's done a fantastic
job of really socializing them and just
getting them to be look how wonderful
they are I mean they're so mellow which
is really great but they're perfect I
love Pippa just hanging out with me you
know do they come as a pair or don't
need to be adopted as a pair they can't
get docked it as a pair which is great
but no they don't need to be that would
that wouldn't you like to go with your
brother somewhere yes I think you would
um now tell us a little bit about the
event that is happening at present yes
so we're actually we have a great
partnership with Pet Smart so we are
there actually Monday through Saturday
from 10:00 to 2:00 so we've got great
dogs and we've got cats and kittens like
these guys that works over there yeah
now when it comes to adopting a kitten
tell us like what kind of time could you
need to dedicate to that process I've
never had cats before they seem to be
very independent but also very loving
they are in you know in cats and kittens
especially require a little bit more
time so especially the people that are
home right now this is a really great
time to bond with your kitten and kind
of teach them socialization and kind of
get to get used to your home they are so
mellow I just love this I you might be
turning me from a dog person into a
category
for you yeah now if you want to pick
yourself up a new furry friend a member
of your family why don't you check out
this event it's really cool like you
said it's at Petsmart
the shelter right now is temporarily
closed but we've got plenty of
opportunities for you to find a new
family member there you go right there
the address on a rail crossing Parkway
which is at 215 and Rainbow Monday
through Saturday Pippa and Patrick my
new best friends